[indistinct audio]
- NO! [audience ohs]
- OH!
REJECTED!
[laughter]
MAYBE HE SHOULD JUST BE ONE
OF THOSE INDOOR KIDS THAT READS.
MAYBE MOLLY MAIDS THERE
WILL HELP CLEAN UP YOUR FACE.
[laughter]
THAT DOESN'T LOOK VERY HARD.
I WANT TO TRY.
SCORE.
DO YOU WANT ME TO HONESTLY TELL
YOU HOW MANY TIMES THAT TOOK?
- YEAH.
- ONE.
YOU NEVER SEE RICH PEOPLE WITH
TRAMPOLINES.
[laughter]
IT'S LIKE AN ABOVE-GROUND POOL.
IT'S JUST NOT AN UPSCALE
PIECE OF LAWN FURNITURE.
HEY, AT LEAST THEY SPRUNG
FOR THE SAFETY NET.
WHAT COULD GO WRONG?
WELL, HERE'S ONE THING
THAT COULD GO WRONG.
THE KIDS COULD START
DOUBLE-BOUNCING
THE [bleep]
OUT OF EACH OTHER.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
WHAT A DOUBLE-BOUNCE IS,
IT'S THE TRAMPOLINE EQUIVALENT
OF A SPEEDBALL.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
WHAT A SPEEDBALL IS,
IT'S WHAT KILLED JOHN BELUSHI.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
WHO JOHN BELUSHI IS,
HE'S JIM BELUSHI'S BROTHER.
FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO DON'T KNOW WHO JIM IS,
HE'S THE GUY
FROM ACCORDING TO JIM.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DIDN'T
WATCH ACCORDING TO JIM,
CONGRATULATIONS.
OH, WOW, IS HE UP THERE.
SOMEBODY JUST CAUGHT FIRE
NBA JAM STYLE.
SAVOR THE MOMENT, SCOTTY SKILES,
'CAUSE IT'S ABOUT TO TURN SOUR.
[audience oohs]
THAT'S A TECHNICAL FOUL.
GET OFF THE RIM.
YEAH, SUCK IT, VINCE CARTER.
DANGLING BY YOUR ELBOW?
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
SUCH A BIG DEAL ANYMORE.
- AHH!
- MMM. IT HURTS TO HEAR.
THIS IS WHERE HE
AND HIS TORN ACL
COULD LEARN A LESSON
FROM SASHA.
JUST DISTRIBUTE THE BALL,
SET SOME SCREENS,
AND DRAW DEFENDERS
OUT OF THE LANE
SO REAL PLAYERS
CAN PUT ON A SHOW.
- [whimpering]
- AND WHY IS HE CRYING
LIKE NANCY KERRIGAN?
YOU'RE WHITE.
YOU DON'T GET TO DUNK.
BY HAVING GIRLS PLAY THEM.
I DON'T MEAN THE WNBA.
I MEAN GIRL GIRLS.
THERE'S LINGERIE FOOTBALL,
FOXY BOXING, AND STRIPPER GOLF.
BUT LADIES HAVE NOTHING
TO MASTURBATE TO
WHILE THEY WATCH SPORTS,
AND IN MY BOOK, THAT'S SEXIST.
THAT'S WHY I CREATED
THE INTER-SHOWBIZ
BOTTOMLESS BASKETBALL LEAGUE.
- [groans]
[cheers and applause]
- IT'S ALWAYS TOUGH PLAYING
AGAINST THE CAST OF TREME.
FINALLY,
BY NOW EVERYONE KNOWS
INSTEAD OF WINNING BASKETBALL
GAMES THE HONORABLE WAY,
ARIZONA STATE CREATED
THE CURTAIN OF DISTRACTION
TO SCREW WITH THE OPPOSING TEAM
WHILE THEY'RE TAKING FOUL SHOTS.
[LAUGHS]
YEAH, THAT'S INNOCENT ENOUGH,
BUT THEN THEY STARTED
TO GET A LITTLE PERSONAL.
>> YOUR TEST RESULTS ARE IN.
YOU HAVE HODGKIN'S
AND NON-HODGKIN'S AND HERPES!
YOU GOT THE HERP!
>> HODGKIN'S AND NON-HODGKIN'S
CANCEL EACH OTHER OUT.
THIS NEXT ONE I THOUGHT
WAS REALLY SCARY.
>> [LAUGHS] HOO!
YOU CAN'T RID OF THE BABADOOK.
YEAH! NOBODY CAN GET RID
OF THE BABADOOK. WHOO!
>> YOU DON'T MESS
WITH THE BABADOOK.
THAT'S JUST IRRESPONSIBLE.
THIS ONE WAS
A DOWNRIGHT TEARJERKER.
>> THERE HE IS. THERE'S MY DADDY
AT THE FREE THROW LINE.
PLEASE DO THE RIGHT THING
AND RAISE ME.
>> IS THAT A MIXED BABY?
YOU GIVE ME THAT MIXED BABY.
I WILL HAPPILY RAISE HIM.
I'M NOT GONNA LIE, I FOUND THIS
NEXT ONE A LITTLE OFFENSIVE.
>> EINS, ZWEI, DREI, VIER.
I DECLARE A THUMB WAR.
>> AH, JESUS!
>> COME ON ADOLF, NOBODY [BLEEP]
WITH THE JESUS!
AND THEN, JUST WHEN YOU THOUGHT
THEY COULDN'T BE
ANY MORE DISTRACTING,
YOU HEARTLESS MONSTERS GO
AND DO THIS.
>> WE'VE GOT YOUR MOM!
READ THIS.
>> "MISS THE FREE
THROW, PLEASE."
>> KEEP UP THOSE BRUTAL TACTICS,
ASU,
AND YOU MAY ACTUALLY GET OFF
THAT NIT BUBBLE.
WOMEN ARE ALWAYS TRYING TO TRAP
MEN BY GETTING PREGNANT.
WHICH IS CRAZY BECAUSE RUINING
YOUR BODY
PERMANENTLY SEEMS LIKE
A GUARANTEED WAY
TO MAKE SURE
I DON'T STICK AROUND.
BUT THIS NEXT GIRL'S PRANK
TAKES IT A LITTLE TOO FAR.
>> HI. SORRY. I'M ANDREA.
UM, DO YOU NOT
RECOGNIZE ME AT ALL?
YOUR BOYFRIEND GOT ME PREGNANT,
AND HE'S GONNA
HELP ME OUT WITH IT.
HE GOT ME PREGNANT AT A PARTY.
ARE YOU GONNA
HELP ME AT ALL OR...
>> YEAH, OF COURSE.
HEY, I GOT YOU.
>> NOT FUNNY.
A GIRL TRIED THE PREGNANT
BASKETBALL PRANK ON ME ONCE,
OH, BUT I THINK
I HANDLED IT PRETTY WELL.
>> HEY, THIS IS YOURS.
YOU GOT ME PREGNANT.
>> ARE YOU SURE?
>> I'M SURE.
>> I'M SORRY, HONEY.
I HAVE TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
>> [GIGGLES]
>> WHAT?
>> WHO'S THE BABY?
YOU SEE THE DOGGY?
PEDAL! PEDAL! PEDAL! PEDAL!
DUNK IT!
YAY! I REMEMBER MY PROM.
ALL RIGHT, ONE LAST PHOTO.
I COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OF YOU,
SON.
[CAMERA SHUTTER CLICKS]
SHORTLY AFTER THAT...
I'M SORRY.
HE ROLLED INTO THE STREET
AND WAS HIT BY A CAR.
NO PARENT SHOULD EVER HAVE
TO BURY THEIR BASKETBALL.
OKAY, GOOD NIGHT.
BEFORE I GO,
I HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION:
WOULD YOU RATHER?